I'm saying at what point would you mark  that life is life why is it is it 24  that it is illegal or is it 22. I know  it's got 22. is 24 weeks it's 24 weeks  but it's illegal but if there's any kind  of perceived abnormalities we're up  until birth and so there's actually  um statistics I can't remember the top  of my head where you know with the Down  Syndrome or even cleft lip palette I  don't know what that is um  yeah that's that's a perceived yeah  Beyond 24 weeks you can get so if if  someone had a clef like because that's  when your when your lip is just yeah but  they can fix that yeah yeah and so that  is that in the UK and the us or just the  UK I don't know about the U.S